the village of luzarat will soon be a
memory it's been demolished to make way
for the expansion of a vast open cast
coal mine the only occupants left are
protesters determined to frustrate the
diggers but they're outnumbered by
police officers sent from all across
Germany
their job is to get the activists out to
enable luthority's destruction
these people have just been expelled
up here it's getting over this over the
budget the mine expands relentlessly a
precipice that inches towards you
and watching over it still protesters on
poles and in tree houses they are human
barriers and from this vantage point you
can see exactly why this is such a focal
point 20 meters over to my left is the
edge of the mine encroaching ever
towards litterat but look over to my
right up in the trees there are still
protesters holding out while the police
tried to get them out of this small
crucial Village
the huge digging machines Loom over this
Countryside
who's came today to join a demonstration
against the expansion
among them perhaps the world's best
known climate activist they should stop
what's happening here immediately stop
the destruction and ensure climate
Justice for everyone they squelched
through mud and rain and confronted the
police
there is real anger here and at times it
boiled over
Germany has a green party in its
government but an energy plan that
involves more coal and for many that's
confusing yeah it's difficult to
understand why they made such a deal
because it was clear that Luther had the
village of Lutheran will be a symbol of
a climate protest and a deal would have
been much better that avoids that and
uses alternatives
luterath is now more Rubble than
anything else but the protests rumble on
neither the people nor the village are
going quietly out of Parsons Sky News
luta